[Musik]
freiwillig und kostenlos wer aus dem
ausland zurückkehrt kann künftig gratis
einen corona test machen
historisch und umstritten nach 86 jahren
gibt es in der hagia sophia wieder ein
muslimisches freitagsgebet und leinen
los mit halber kraft erstmals legt
wieder ein großes kreuzfahrtschiff von
einem deutschen hafen ab
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg freitag der 24 juli
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
alles wunderbar von mir
es ist der versuch zu verhindern dass
urlauber eine neue corona welle auslösen
mitten in der sommerferien hochsaison
haben sich die gesundheitsminister von
bund und ländern nun doch auf neue
beschlüsse für reiserückkehrer geeinigt
und zwar diese urlauber die aus
offiziellen risikogebieten zurückkommen
können sich künftig direkt am flughafen
kostenlos testen lassen
das ganze ist freiwillig für alle
anderen urlauber gilt sie bekommen wenn
sie wollen bis zu 72 stunden nach ihrer
heimkehr einen kostenlosen corona test
die details hat jetzt marcus groß
flughafen berlin-tegel ankunft der
urlauber aus dem türkischen antalya ab
nächster woche sollen sich rückkehrer
aus risikogebieten hier aufgrund testen
lassen können ich persönlich bin völlig
der antenne eigentlich da geht man
wirklich ob die nummer sicher eine
quarantäne pflicht gibt es schon länger
doch in der praxis wird das kaum
kontrolliert deshalb nun zusätzlich die
tests an den flughäfen beschlossen wurde
sie sollen freiwillig und kostenlos sein
auch rückreisende aus nicht
risikoländern sollen die möglichkeit
einer testung haben natürlich über
andere wege wie kassenärztliche
vereinigung oder andere test stellen
außerhalb der flughäfen
auch diese testungen werden die kosten
übernommen
denn die sorge ist in der ferienzeit
könnten die infektionen wieder ansteigen
erste infizierte urlauber sind bereits
zurückgekehrt die tests an den flughäfen
nun freiwillig experten hätten lieber
einen verpflichtenden test gesehen doch
darauf konnten sich die
gesundheitsminister nicht einigen
ich glaube die politik sollte hier eine
klare linie geben und nicht das dem
einzelnen überlassen
man sollte wirklich sagen wenn ihr aus
den und den ländern kommt weil wir das
land wirklich für ein risiko halten dann
müsst ihr euch testen
die bayerische gesundheitsministerium
sieht das ähnlich plädiert für
obligatorische tests
ich halte es für richtig weil es im
grunde genommen momentan ihr so ist dass
diejenigen die aus risikogebieten
zurückkommen 14 tage in quarantäne
müssen und nicht jeder hält sich daran
oder nicht jeder weiß es vielleicht und
da würde eine verpflichtende testung uns
schon mal als momentaufnahme sehr viel
helfen die diskussion freiwillig oder
verpflichtend nimmt fahrt auf
unstrittig ist schiff bus und bahn
reisende aus risikogebieten sollen wie
der sogenannte aussteige karten
ausfüllen und an grenzübergängen soll
stichprobenartig kontrolliert werden der
theo koll in berlin warum sind die tests
nicht pflicht nun offensichtlich auch
weil sich alle politisch beteiligten
noch nicht sicher sind ob man reisende
überhaupt zu einem test zwingen darf da
läuft jetzt die juristische prüfung was
gelinde gesagt ziemlich erstaunlich ist
denn in manchen bundesländern kommen die
urlauber ja schon längst wieder zurück
das hätte den gesundheitsministern also
durchaus früher einfallen können der
bayerische ministerpräsident hat schon
am vergangenen sonntag bei uns im zdf
sommer
interview kostenlose test an flughäfen
angekündigt und das bayerische kabinett
wird zu hören wir am kommenden dienstag
über verpflichtende tests entscheiden
das wäre dann allerdings erstmal nur für
bayern
die bisherige regelung des reisende aus
risikogebieten sich bei den
gesundheitsämtern melden müssen um dann
in quarantäne zu gehen die ist ja auch
verbindlich vorgeschrieben aber es hält
sich kaum jemand dran und nicht zu
vergessen angesichts der aktuell wieder
stark steigenden infektionszahlen dürfte
dann am ende die frage der test
verpflichtung ein weiteres mal ganz
nebenbei das image von markus söder als
corona bekämpfer verstärken helfen
dankeschön nach berlin theo koll corona
tests für urlauber an allen deutschen
flughäfen sind die test anbieter auf den
möglichen andrang vorbereitet und welche
länder gelten derzeit als besonders
riskant antworten darauf finden sie auch
in unserer zdf heute app in deutschland
werde es gehört steigt die zahl der chor
ohne neuinfektionen weiter an im schnitt
der vergangenen woche haben sich täglich
490 menschen angesteckt das ergibt sich
aus den zahlen der johns hopkins
universität gestern lag der durchschnitt
noch bei 480 das robert koch institut
zählt sogar allein gestern 815
neuinfektionen und spricht von einer so
wörtlich sehr beunruhigenden entwicklung
kogit 19 fälle gebe es zunehmend unter
reiserückkehrern so das lka gegenüber
dem zdf eine weitere verschärfung der
situation müsse unbedingt vermieden
werden
das gelinge nur wenn sich die gesamte
bevölkerung weiterhin engagieren als im
mai bei der firma tönnies in rheda
wiedenbrück das corona virus auftauchte
waren am ende mehr als 2100 menschen
infiziert wie sich das virus dort so
ausbreiten konnte haben drei
forschungsinstitute untersucht und nun
unter anderem festgestellt das virus
übertrug sich nicht nur über 1,5 meter
sondern auch über eine größere distanz
ralph goldmann hat die details
deutschlands größter schlachthof hat
umgerüstet seit einer woche bieten
plexiglasscheiben schutz
zwischen den arbeitsplätzen ein neues
lüftungssystem soll die luft regelmäßig
reinigen
das alte system hatte die luft nur
umgewälzt und damit die viren über mehr
als acht meter verbreitet
das ist auch das ergebnis einer studie
die die arbeitsbedingungen bei turniers
im mai untersucht hat die luft wird
gekühlt auf zehn grad die wird ständig
oben gewählt
die arbeiter stehen in enger räumlicher
nähe die verrichten körperliche arbeit
ist ja laut die müssen laut sprechen
also das ist einfach eine kombination
von faktoren die mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit dazu geführt hat dass
eben die übertragung dort ziemlich
effizient war und eben über diese
distanzen stattgefunden hat und das
unternehmen will jetzt mit einer masken
pflicht abstandsregeln regelmäßigen
tests und vor allem mit den modernen
filteranlagen eine mögliche verbreitung
des virus in der produktion erschweren
das heißt innerhalb von einem kurzen
zeitraum wird die gesamte raumluft
einmal komplett gefiltert die viren
werden sozusagen herausgenommen und
damit der die luft komplett gereinigt
eine gute lüftung ist aber nur ein
faktor der eine virus ausbreitung
erschweren kann ob die ergebnisse der
studie auch auf andere bereiche wie
sporthallen oder andere
produktionshallen anwendbar sind ist
noch offen
es mag da durchaus bereiche gebe in
denen das auswirkungen hat also dort wo
zum beispiel leute sich körperlich
anstrengen in innenräumen ohne
frischluft zufuhr mag das schon eine
bedeutung haben aber das muss man sich
wirklich im einzelnen anschauen
das lässt sich ohne weiteres glaube ich
nicht unbedingt für allgemein die
wohnsituation der beschäftigten auch das
sagt die studie habe bei der ausbreitung
des virus jedenfalls keine besondere
rolle gespielt
steigende infektionszahlen melden auch
viele andere europäische länder in
österreich und england gehen deswegen
jetzt auf nummer sicher
zuletzt galt die masken pflicht in
österreich nur noch für öffentliche
verkehrsmittel ab jetzt aber wieder in
lebensmittelgeschäften und
krankenhäusern
auch in england ist der mund nasenschutz
seit heute in den läden verpflichtend
eine kehrtwende der britischen regierung
wie wollte eine maske pflicht
ursprünglich unbedingt vermeiden aus
angst die wirtschaft könne dadurch
zusätzlich belastet werden
zwischen china und den usa rumort es
gewaltig nahezu täglich kommt es zu
neuen konfrontation jetzt ordnete peking
an das us konsulat in der stadt chengdu
zu schließen
das ist die reaktion darauf dass die
amerikanische regierung die chinesische
vertretung in texas dicht gemacht hatte
wegen spionagevorwürfen us-außenminister
pompeo warf der chinesischen regierung
vor ein geistiges eigentum und
geschäftsgeheimnisse zu stehlen
ein sprecher des chinesischen
außenministeriums wies die
anschuldigungen suche und roller in
peking wie heikel ist die situation im
moment also ich glaube schon dass das
sehr besorgniserregend ist was da läuft
zwischen china und den usa
täglich gibt es eigentlich neue
konflikte und es gibt kein politikfeld
das nicht umstritten ist vor allem
rhetorisch hat man doch ältesten hin
aufgerüstet rhetorisch das heißt man
wirft sich gegenseitig vor dass man sich
zerstören will
es gibt ein detail was sehr spannend
heute ist die chinesen haben erwartbar
reagiert aber doch relativ verhalten
indem sie das konsulat von genco
geschlossen haben sie hätten auch ein
konsulat schließen können in shanghai
oder in hongkong das hätte eine
wesentlich größere symbolik gehabt und
wir auch wirtschaftlich wesentlich
problematischer gewesen für beide länder
also da sieht man dass china doch sich
zurückhält in diesem konflikt aber nicht
desto trotz es ist ein kalter krieg
zwischen diesen beiden weltmächten und
das heißt für die welt nichts gutes und
vor allem auch für europa dass europa
droht immer mehr zwischen diesen zwei
weltmächten zerrieben zu werden
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
roller war das live aus peking
die meisten corona neuinfektionen gibt
es nach wie vor in den usa vor allem im
floyd
das ist nicht die richtige zeit für
großveranstaltungen
das sieht nun auch der präsident ein und
traf eine für ihn schwierige
entscheidung
er sagte den nominierungsparteitag der
republikaner in jacksonville ab 19 1000
delegierte sollten donald trump dort
ende august offiziell zum
präsidentschaftskandidaten küren
es fühle sich einfach falsch an menschen
in einen
hotspot zu schicken so trump mit großer
erleichterung hat außenminister maße auf
die freilassung der im irak entführten
deutschen reagiert heller mevis hier
archivfotos war am montag von
unbekannten in bagdad verschleppt worden
sie leitet dort kunstprogramm am morgen
haben irakische behörden sie in die
deutsche botschaft gebracht ihr gehe es
den umständen entsprechend gut
ein historischer und sehr umstrittener
moment heute in istanbul in der hagia
sophia gab es erstmals wieder ein
muslimisches freitagsgebet das
weltberühmte gebäude war fast 1000 jahre
lang die größte kirche des christentums
dann moschee ein museum
und jetzt auf geheiß des türkischen
präsidenten erdogan wieder moschee trotz
aller internationaler proteste aus
istanbul der phase seit seiner jugend
habe er davon geträumt irgendwann mal
wieder in der hagia sophia zu beten für
präsident erdogan war dieses
freitagsgebet somit eine genugtuung
unsere nation hatte viele jahre lang
diese sehnsucht für uns war das sehr
wichtig und es ist gut dass wir alle
durch unseren gemeinsamen einsatz diese
sehnsucht befriedigen konnten die
nutzung als museum für alle konfessionen
1934 von staatsgründer atatürk verfügt
war für ihn ein historischer fehler der
papst hatte die entscheidung das einst
wichtigste gotteshaus der christen
wieder als moschee zu nutzen kritisiert
wenn ich an die hagia sophia denke sagte
franziskus dann empfinde ich großen
schmerz für die muslimischen gläubigen
aber die sich heute zu tausenden vor der
basilika versammelt hatten war es ein
tag des nationalen triumph ist das
symbol des sieges der osmanen über die
christlichen byzantiner gehört nun
wieder ihnen
wir sind seit einer woche schon ganz
aufgeregt gott segne unsere nation und
unseren präsidenten heute ist der tag an
dem wir muslime wieder stark sind
präsident erdogan hatte sich jede
einmischung von außen verbieten die
nutzung der hagia sophia so erdogan sei
allein sache der türkei für viele
bedeutet der heutige tag den endgültigen
abschied von einer säkularen türkei
präsident erdogan bricht ganz bewusst
mit diesem erbe von staatsgründer
atatürk er will das zeichen senden einer
stolzen starken und vor allem
islamischen türkei ungeachtet aller
kritik aus dem ausland
die türkische führung betonte dass die
adia sofia nach dem gebet wieder allen
besuchern offen stehen würde
dauerhafte veränderungen am historischen
bauwerk sei nicht geplant
seit jahren beklagen hilfsorganisationen
die dramatischen zustände auf den
griechischen inseln zehntausende leben
dort in völlig überfüllten
flüchtlingslagern
es fehlt an platz und waschmöglichkeiten
an medizinischer versorgung
nun hat deutschland erneut einige von
ihnen aufgenommen am morgen starteten 18
kranke kinder mit ihren familien in
athen nach der landung ging es für die
insgesamt 83 geflüchteten in mehrere
bundesländer
dort müssen sie regulär asyl beantragen
zehn jahre ist es her dass die party in
einer katastrophe endete 21 menschen
kamen bei der loveparade in duisburg ums
leben mehr als 650 wurden verletzt
an sie erinnern hinterbliebene und
überlebende in diesen minuten ganz in
der nähe des ortes der am 24 juli 2010
zur tödlichen falle wurde die hauptrampe
war eingang und ausgang des party
geländes hier stauten sich zu viele
menschen es kam zum gedränge den
strafprozess stellte das landgericht
duisburg anfang mai endgültig ein
in hamburg liegt heute erstmals wieder
ein großes kreuzfahrtschiff von einem
deutschen hafen ab seit märz hatten die
ozeanriesen weltweit zwangspause die
folge milliardenverluste für eine
branche die sich zuvor über fantastische
wachstumszahlen freuen konnte
rund 30 millionen passagiere pro jahr
sorgten zuletzt für fast 1,2 millionen
arbeitsplätze
nun soll es langsam wieder losgehen
christiansen der erste trip ist er ein
ausflug als eine kreuzfahrt für drei
tage geht es von hamburg richtung
nordsee statt sonst fast 3000
passagieren fährt jetzt weniger als die
hälfte mit
für die reederei ein testlauf auf
kreuzfahrtschiffe corona sicher
betrieben werden können
dabei setzen wir wie auch an land üblich
auf prävention vor während und nach der
reise auf abstand halten auf zusätzliche
hygienemaßnahmen kennen wir alle viele
hände waschen an bord sollen masken
getragen werden wären die abstandsregeln
nicht eingehalten werden können keine
selbstbedienung in den restaurants die
crew frisch corona getestet landgänge
gibt es nicht ich denke mal die für
unsere sicherheit ist gesorgt und wir
verlassen uns auch darauf im grunde
spielt sich alles so ab wie an land
wenn sie jetzt ein restaurant besuchen
maske auf ich hoffe dass einigermaßen
entspannt ist wie ein kreuz schreibt
junkies und haben jetzt die letzte über
ein jahr her und wurde zeit dass mal
wieder losgeht monate lang lagen
weltweit mehr als 400 kreuzfahrt schiffe
vor anker das geschäft komplett
eingebrochen die ersten reedereien haben
bereits insolvenz angemeldet
ich denke tatsächlich dass die kleine
reedereien wirklich die die nicht so
viele schiffe haben und nicht diese
riesige kreditlinie haben wirklich
liquiditätsschwierigkeiten bekommen
können und ich gehe davon aus dass eine
konzentration in der branche stattfindet
die aida reederei musste heute ihre
erste kurzreise anfang august wieder
absagen
mehrere crewmitglieder kamen mit dem
corona virus aus ihren heimatländern
normalerweise kommen jedes jahr
millionen besucher auf das oktoberfest
in münchen dieses jahr ist es wegen
corona abgesagt harte zeiten auch für
die schausteller
jetzt aber gibt es in münchen eine art
sommer ersatz kein klassisches volksfest
aber fahrgeschäfte mit ein bisschen
jahrmarkt und kleinkunst und zwar gut
sechs wochen lang verteilt auf über 20
orte in der stadt
jetzt hast du norbert erfreulich ist
zumindest für alle freunde des
motorsports
allerdings nennen die formel 1 die macht
in diesem jahr nun doch noch eine
station in deutschland und zwar auf dem
nürburgring am 11 oktober soll dort der
elfte saison lauf ausgetragen werden als
großer preis der eifel nach sieben
jahren pause das formel 1 comeback auf
der traditionsstrecke
es ist eine rückkehr die überraschend
kommt hatten sich die betreiber der
rennstrecke doch die antrittsgage die
die formel 1 normalerweise aufruft
zuletzt nicht mehr leisten können und
wollen jetzt haben wir ein glück
gefunden in der konstruktiven und
partnerschaftlichen gesprächen der uns
nicht von unserer maxime abbrechen lässt
das heißt wir werden die schwarze null
steht sebastian vettel hatte 2013 noch
für red bull
das letzte rennen auf dem nürburgring
gewonnen in deutschland war der
hockenheimring zuletzt austragungsort
der formel
der allerdings hatte gestern abgesagt
und so soll nun der nürburgring den
letzten block der europarennen eröffnen
was man das alles ohne zuschauer geplant
also die genehmigungs lage gibt es einen
mental noch nicht her das kennen wir aus
dem fußball
bis oktober aber könnte auch da ein
konzept stehen dass einige zuschauer
wieder zulässt
heute sollten wir eigentlich die
olympischen sommerspiele in tokio
eröffnet werden
wegen corona aber verschiebung um ein
jahr und dann mit sommer 2021 das größte
sportereignis der welt stattfinden kann
ist weiterhin ungewiss
das symbol in der hand aber allein im
stadion die japanische schwimmerin rica
kubicki corona hat alles verändert
ein event gigantisch präsentiert so soll
es 20 21 wieder sein
doch sind spiele überhaupt möglich
weltweit sind die infektionsraten auf
rekordhöhe
es wird ein anderes olympia wohl ohne
zuschauer da haben wir zwar olympisch
aber wir haben auch keine spiele so
richtig eine olympische organisationen
die ihr event absolviert geisterspiele
das will ioc präsident dr thomas bach
vermeiden
am ende dieser sehr schwierigen zeit für
die menschen können die olympischen
spiele ein symbol der hoffnung sein
von optimismus wie man das kind wird es
sicherlich nicht wohl eher olympia light
wäre ja auch schon was in 364 müssen
positiv denken
das wochenende bringt nicht nur aber
auch schauer oder gewitter die details
hat gleich aus den termin christian sieh
was freut sich auf sie um 10 im
heute-journal und hier übernimmt morgen
petra gerster die gesamte heute
redaktion bedankt sich für ihr interesse
und wünsche ihnen ein schönes wochenende
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter vom vereinigten königreich her
erreicht uns allmählich ein tief und das
bringt hier regenwolken mit schon im
tagesverlauf beginnt es von westen her
zu regnen
aber dann in der darauf folgenden nacht
dann kräftiger regen aus westen
wir schauen wer es in die kommende nacht
da gibt es im süden etwas regen viel
wird es nicht sein sonst ist es trocken
9 bis 16 grad die tiefsten temperaturen
und morgen zum vormittag im westen erste
schauer und kompakte wolken im süden
viel sonnenschein von südwesten bis
richtung sachsen zum nachmittag kommen
dann mehr wolken im westen auf vor allem
dann richtung ems und in die mitte
regnet es in sachsen gibt es einzelne
schauer südlich des mains aber
überwiegend trockenes wetter und das bei
temperaturen bis 29 grad im südwesten
und 22 grad entlang der küsten ein recht
warmer tag am sonntag gibt es kräftige
schauer und gewitter
und die können kräftig sein bis 28 grad
und am montag da wird es schon wieder
bisschen ruhiger bis 32 grad heiß und
noch heiser am dienstag bis 34 grad
ein schöner amt